[Music]
welcome everyone thank you for coming to
building for trust hope you're enjoying
the last few hours of GCP next this year
my co-presenter just Frizzell and I are
going to talk about how to run container
securely using Google container engine
so before I introduce her and she
introduces me I thought I'd mentioned
the context that we're gonna assume you
have if this is your first time hearing
about kubernetes and you don't know
about containers this talk may be a
little too high level for you you can
either find something else to go listen
to or just follow along as best you can
so we are going to assume you have
general knowledge of some of these
things my co-presenter here is just for
zell she's on the Google container
engine security team and also works on
kubernetes she recently drove a lot of
the process improvements for doing
security vulnerabilities and disclosure
and patching that before she joined
Google she was working on docker itself
and was involved in a lot of the Linux
security module support in that system
Jess I'll introduce Alex more my
coworker and the technical lead and
manager of some of the Google container
engine teams including platform security
for two and a half years he's worked on
gke and then before that he worked on
the Google compute engine so what we're
gonna cover today is like a basic
outline is security boundaries identity
and access management runtime security
and a demo and then the kubernetes
roadmap for the future so let's just
dive right into the security boundaries
we have these various security models
the way it works today is a single
tenant there's one trust boundary which
is your entire cluster and all users are
admin but with some features coming in
kubernetes 1.6 including role based
authentication which we'll cover more in
depth later we are moving into a
different model where single tenant
multiple identities there's multiple
users
no really enforcement but you still
treat the entire cluster as your
boundary so as long as you create
multiple clusters for various projects
or teams that you don't trust to be on
the same one then you're totally fine
and of course spitting up clusters and
gke is super easy like command-line
tools or you can use the UI and then
we'll move into a more cooperative soft
multi-tenancy where this is more
multi-user fine-grain authorization
permissions it's not entirely fully
hardened but it's good enough for
multi-tenancy inside the same company
you can control you know bad actors and
remove them from the cluster so what the
single tenant kind of looks like is you
have your entire cluster as a boundary I
team one and Team two you trust to be on
the same cluster so you put them there
otherwise you'd have a new cluster for
whoever that is and so you have their
front-end apps and their databases
running on the same cluster as each
other all the nodes have the same
authentication identity all pods have
the same authorization permissions and
all pods have network access so now I'll
pass it back to Alex to cover Identity
and Access Management Thank You Jess so
let's talk about Identity and Access
Management the first part of this is
authentication that is who are you we'll
talk in a little bit about authorization
you know what can you do so user
authentication who are you if you are
the little puppet in the upper right
corner there you want to access a gke
cluster one way of doing that is using
bearer tokens and another way of doing
that with container engine is that you
can use Google OAuth to access tokens so
for example if you have run that line on
the top after you've authenticated with
Google using g-cloud off login you can
go get credentials for a given cluster
and that will configure your cube
control config file such that it will
use those credentials when accessing
your cluster when you then issue your
cube control create command passing in
some yellow file that you want to be
have created then what will happen is
your request will be sent to the gke
cluster the API server that's hosted for
you
and it will receive that request the
Google OAuth to tokens will be included
in there and those will then be
forwarded to GCPs I am service to verify
them if that happens then the responses
passed back to the API server that runs
on your cluster and you'll then be
authenticated as your identity users are
not the only identity that we care about
we also have many system components so a
kubernetes cluster is not just a single
thing we have the gke master which has
controllers and API servers and many
other bits but your cluster also
consists of the nodes that are
participating in it so the master itself
has a certificate authority one CA for
the entire cluster and the Masters then
given certificates that are signed by
that CA at the same time the nodes in
the cluster are also given node
certificates and keys that are also
signed by that same CA and when we
create these nodes on your behalf we
pass along the details of what those
node certificates are in the VM metadata
server that these nodes are running on
and so then the nodes are able to fetch
that key and that cert down from the
metadata server and when they contact
the master then you get mutual
authentication so the nodes are gonna
invest verify the master cert when
they're talking to it to make sure that
it's really the master that they expect
it to be and of course at the same time
then the master can verify that the node
is coming with a cert that is signed by
that CA and therefore it should be
allowed to join the cluster and this is
important to stop nodes that you do not
want to be part of your cluster from
joining it the third pillar of
authentication we have is for workloads
so in kubernetes has support for the
things running inside your cluster to
also have identities so maybe you want
to have a cron job style service that
runs inside your cluster and your cron
job is going to do something every hour
like contact the API server to create a
particular pod or a deployment or
replica set whatever it wants to do
every hour and in that case the thing
that's running in my cluster needs to
have some form of mechanism for
identifying itself to that API server so
it will have permissions to do what it
wants to do so there are two parts to
this on the left you can see we have
kubernetes
service accounts and the way these are
implemented is that there's a surface
account controller that runs and it
signs any jots for all of the service
accounts in the system so if there's a
service account a job will be created
for it and those jots then gets stored
in the API as secrets and so then when
you want to create something that uses a
given service account you can specify
for your pod please use specified
service account and if you don't specify
a surface account currently the default
is the that you will inherit the
namespaces default service account and
currently that namespaces default
service account usually gives you full
access to the cluster so once your pod
is running it has this access to the
secret and the secret will be then
mounted at a known location in the pons
file system and so when you make one to
make your request to the API server your
pods can then read in that shot they can
use it as a bearer token and they make
that request to the kubernetes api
server and therefore they will be
authenticated and of course the api
server will allow you to do that so
again if you wanted a cron job or
anything along those lines maybe you
have a third party resource that you
want to extend the api server with you
can do that and the service accounts
provide you a mechanism for doing that
without having long-lived bearer
credentials that are outside of the
system so that's authentication let's
talk about authorization so given your
identity or an identity that what can
you do with it
today kubernetes supports what's called
at least carlton kubernetes a back off
tribute based access control this is
really just a very simple file based
authorization policy if you're running
kubernetes yourself you could configure
it with more details but with container
engine today it's a static file that
basically supports only an admin
identity what we'd like to do and is
offer people more fine-grained access
control than that and so what we've been
doing is moving with some of the people
in the community to get roles based
access control which is another
authorization mechanism that the
kubernetes api server will support and
this is going to allow for a much
fine-grain authorization and you can
also configure it using the kubernetes
API itself so the configuration
mechanism is through the API you can
create I'll talk a little bit more about
that in a minute roles and role bindings
and so on and so that won't give you
full control to configure the
permissions in your cluster
so what is the basic usage of auerbach
if you look on the left there you we
have one of the resource types and
kubernetes is a pod that might contain
multiple containers and the API server
supports to access mechanisms you can
call get on the pod and maybe you can
call lists on a pot or also a whole
bunch more like create and delete but
for this simple example we'll just focus
on list and get and maybe on the far
right up there I've got the user in blue
and I want to be able to say hey this
user should be able to call get on pods
they should be able to list the pods in
the system so how am I going to do that
with our back the first step is to
create a role that's the gray box we
might create a pod reader role and this
basically says anyone who is a member of
the pod reader role has that capability
they can call get on pods they can call
list on pods and life will be good so I
then need the final piece of this is a
role binding that's the green box which
says this particular user can is bound
to this particular role if they have
authenticated themselves as this
particular user they have this role
available to them and so then de user
comes in the authorization system looks
and says ok you're you know Alex Moore
at google.com
at those roles yes you do have the pod
reader role there's a binding there
between them you're trying to call pod
get no problem everything succeeds so
that's the basic usage auerbach supports
a lot more complexity even in this case
if you said well what if I have nodes as
well maybe I want to have in the bottom
gray box over there a node pod reader
role and that might allow anyone with
that role to be able to both list pods
as well as get and list on nodes and the
bindings in this case also can be
extended they don't just have to be
plain users when your users are
authenticated they may come with a set
of groups associated with them so if
you're authenticated as more Akoo
calm and maybe I'm in a group you know
cluster admins then the cluster admin
group could be given the node pod reader
role and it's also not limited just to
users and groups of course but service
accounts can also be be part of these
things and although I don't cover it in
the slides here there are many more
forms of this limited to namespaces
there are cluster roles and so on so
it's a pretty decent authorization
system that gives you a lot of control
if you'd like to use it there you go
so the third pillar of I am you have
authentication authorization the third a
is often referred to as auditing so
right now the gke cluster API is
integrated with GCP audit logging it's
currently in beta and we currently
support the admin activity form of this
for cluster modifications so if you're
gonna create a cluster you're gonna
upgrade a cluster maybe you're gonna
change the node pools in a cluster
you're going to delete a cluster all of
those kinds of admin right actions are
going to be reflected in an audit log
and so it's more or less what you would
expect in the simple form Alice at
example.com created cluster Foom a few
lines later you know Jo at example.com
deleted the cluster bar the details in
here include all of the request
information they include the response
that we send back they include the
identity that did a timestamp cluster IP
pretty rich set of metadata about each
of these requests and those are then
sent to stackdriver logging so you can
go and use the any of the standard
stackdriver logging api is to go look
through that and of course the Google
Cloud console also offers a relatively
nice overview where you can see via the
API sorry via the UI what's been going
on in your clusters drill downs and so
on also available on the bottom data
access this is a very commonly requested
feature you're starting to see more and
more of Google cloud platform products
include data access this would be a log
of all of the read operations being done
so if somebody is calling a list node
pools or something like get cluster
credentials those are the kinds of
things you might expect to see in the
data access logs
and then finally in this section I
wanted to talk briefly about secrets
so the previous section was talking
about authorizing to the kubernetes
cluster itself what if I need to do
something like access a database and I
need a password for that database a
username password combo or what if I
want to make calls to github and its API
maybe I need an access token in order to
do that so secrets are a really nice
kubernetes feature that allow you to do
that you can store other static
credentials having nothing to do with
kubernetes in those secrets you can then
use pods Yamal in order to reference
these secrets and then when you actually
have these secrets of in your pod you
can access them via a file mount or an
environment variable and you can
configure how they get exposed to your
app that runs one of the nice thing
about file mounts is that if you change
your secrets
eventually the file mount will also be
updated to do it so if you have anything
that is rotating these things over time
you can just continually update the
secret and then based on pulling
intervals in time to live on the
cubelets
your app as long as it's going to be
pulling its file mount on a regular
basis should pick up those changes as
they happen so to give you a brief
example of how that works and the code
snippets on the upper right you can see
that the username in this case is admin
and kubernetes EML does base64 encoding
for these so that's the ywr string maybe
we have a fun password like 1 ft 2 D etc
that's also base64 encoded and so in
order to specify the secret we specify
the API version the kind metadata give
it a name my secret and then we pass in
the data as a username and password
field so that's all for I am for the for
now I'm going to pass it back to Jess
who's going to talk about run time
security and give us a really neat demo
so run time security yay containers so I
just wanted to briefly cover the
isolation kind of primitives that make
up containers themselves so if you don't
know already containers aren't real
things like when you create a container
it's not like actually creating this
thing that's called a container it's
using
Linux primitives that are namespaces and
C groups to do this namespaces control
what a process can see and see groups
control what a process can use which is
like the very clear distinction between
the two so as far as namespaces goes
there's a bunch that you can use you can
control what processes are being seen
mounts networks utss hostname IPC is
like messaging queues user namespaces
creates a unprivileged user if you want
and it will be mapped to a different
user under actual host and then there's
also a C group namespace just to confuse
everyone which controls what C groups
you can actually see as far as C groups
go you can control things like how much
memory will be used CPU you can set a
container to run on a specific CPU set
so if you want it to run on like 0 or 1
you can do that you can control what
devices are being used network priority
freezing processes and threads and block
i/o so writing to disk bandwidth and
stuff like that so there's really a lot
of like leverage for you to kind of take
the groundwork here and then build on
top of them with more hardening aspects
of Linux which we'll cover now so one of
these is a Parmer and this is a Linux
security module this is super helpful
for you know creating profiles that will
define what your process like wants to
write to so you can set certain files as
read-only without citing the entire
amount is read-only which is insanely
helpful because read-only file systems
are great but it's very hard to make an
actual application run entirely that's
where you don't like you're gonna need
to write to something so a primer is
great for that you can also deny system
functions like mount net raw stuff like
that it doesn't cover all system
functions there's only just like a small
subset and we're gonna push towards like
saying defaults here docker has the same
default that prevents for
Proc prevents rating this is all the
things that you should not be doing
regardless unless you are running as a
privileged container and preventing
amount so this is beta and kubernetes
and if you want to use it you can do the
following and create an annotation for
your container that points to this and
what we're doing here is using runtime
default which will then use the docker
default profile per year basic and
genetics container that we have here
so moving on another one of these is set
comp and set comp gives you more
leverage over all the Siskel's so a
primer you could do a few like mount but
seccomp you can define like a whitelist
or a blacklist of syscalls that your
application is going to use so in docker
there is a whitelist and it has some
really same defaults when like we were
working on writing it I went through all
the past Seabees that were super bad and
we block things like pee trace and
cloning new on privileged namespaces
which has like the highest CBE rate for
breaking out of containers there are
things that like if your application is
not running as privileged you probably
don't need anyways so for like 95% that
use cases it works out of the box which
is great so this is alpha in kubernetes
so if you want to use this it's kind of
the same thing as before you set the a
notation on your container and for this
one we're using docker default profile
so there's a bunch of other things that
you can set as well you can set as a
Linux context for labels on volumes that
you have in your containers you can run
all your containers in a pod adds a non
root user or ensure that that's
happening you can set a read-only root
filesystem which like I said if that's
impossible for your application you can
actually define granular lelee these
things and a per profile instead and
then you can also add or drop
capabilities to your containers if you
do not need them so what this looks like
if you want to say draw
that raw which really isn't all that
useful unless we want to use ping you
could do this in the security context
for each container and then you can also
set you know Linux options and labels
like I said on your containers you can
define that you want it to be a
read-only root filesystem and you can
also make sure that all containers are
running as a non root user so now we're
gonna do a demo and switch to the other
computer cool okay so this will be fun
so I have like a gke cluster that I spun
up that's running in alpha mode so that
we can use set comp so you could do the
same if you want
so we'll just get another terminal since
this one's dead well that was fun so
we'll just show that there are no pods
currently running fresh cluster cool so
we can have our way with this so I have
first off this fun pod that we're gonna
spin up that is cool so if we look at
our first ball it's gonna create five
replicas if we look here it's just a
simple app named echo which spins up
nginx and nginx just echoes out a bunch
of like header information and the body
of the request and it's just a stupid
demo F then we have like our nginx
configs and we're exposing for Daisy and
we're not doing anything in this example
with annotations and seccomp I just want
to show that we can do things that we
should not be able to do so we'll spin
this one up with a cube CTL create
right so we'll just see that our pods
are running and I'll just like grab one
of these random ones and we can exec in
and and I'll set the container is echo
and we'll run bash so now we're in
hacker voice just kidding so I'm gonna
try to do something that if this you
know what's running it into the next
container and I was actually like you
know escape to the application if I try
to like unshare or something like you
use your namespace to break out we would
not want this to happen but of course
you know it works because nothing's
being blocked I'm not running with any
set comp and kind of blows so that's
with Alex at combi if we look at this
other one that I have that actually does
add a second profile it's the exact same
as our echo application this one I just
named nginx there's five replicas again
because it's cluster might as well use
it and we're setting docker default as
our second profile so by default we know
since I wrote it that's I'm sure being a
new user news face is going to be blocks
so let's just verify that by spending
this up with another keep CTL create
will make sure that these are up
and then I'll just grab another one of
these we're gonna Mele animal exec in
the container our name is Engine IX a in
bash again so now we'll unshare and be
evil and it's denied so that just
basically verifies that it works but
that was like no fun basically so let's
kind of go into a more real-world
example here of trying to stop a bad
person so I have another cluster here
that I'm going to switch to and on this
cluster it just so happens that this has
been me forgot to upgrade one of the
nodes after the dirty cow vulnerability
so the interesting thing about dirty cow
if you all didn't know when at first
when I first heard about it what I do
with these types of vulnerabilities is
I'll try and make sure that the docker
second profile kind of either prevents
it or that we can edit it in such a way
that it will be prevented for everyone
that uses it so when I first heard about
dirty cow I was like crap that one's not
actually prevented by the default
because it's using I'm advised it's
using literally nothing bad you're just
writing to a read-only memory map and
using all the skills that people use
daily
which is hard but what I did know was
that it needed we look here you needed
em advised and you needed em advised
don't need so I was thinking to myself
you know that's just not allowed that
will allow everything of em advised but
not an advice donate so I like had this
patch ready to send like when the
vulnerability was going to be publicly
disclosed and I was just like waiting on
it and it turns out actually and
realized this before the patch was made
which is good
Geel obscene malik uses em advised don't
need like literally all the time so that
would break almost all applications by
default like it could
via default for anyone so that's this
one is very troublesome
so if scissors been me is thinking about
my cluster and for some reason we don't
use G LOC for any of it I could be like
okay I'm going to for the time being
before I upgrade all the nodes and
before I realized if we've been affected
by this or you know anyone got in I'm
going to deploy all these pods with this
custom second profile like I showed that
takes em advised don't need it allows
literally all of em advised but I'm
advising so the order of operations I'm
gonna show these is in a specific order
because after I pone the node then I
can't spin up more containers on it so
we're first gonna show blocking it so
says 'add mean me takes my pods back
here and I'm like I'm gonna use this
custom profile that I put so it's
basically a fork of the defaults that
adds that and I'm going to run this pop
container which basically tries to
exploits the dirty pal ulnar ability and
since I labeled my nodes which in real
life this isn't probably did it but I
did for the sake of this demo to make
sure it goes on the bad node it this is
going to run on the dirty cow node so if
we spin this one up
and let's get our pods cool so let's
grab this one and get some logs okay so
it tried to pawn the machine and it was
like could not pone and now our sad
hacker is that which is great so we
prevented that it gave the system in
time to upgrade stuff or you know assess
if we had been affected which is cool so
another system in comes along maybe also
me and forgets you know to do this
forgets to add to second profile forget
to even write this I come from file just
like does not care so we have another
one of these where it's gonna run on
dirty cow it's gonna run the same exact
container pop and we're not gonna have
any set come I had to do this one second
because I the note just literally will
not respond after this so let's delete
the old
and now we'll create the new
and now let's get our pods cool and now
we'll grab the logs from this one and so
game over like we could write to this
read-only memory map we had all these em
advised calls just like totally killing
the note itself so that's the sad story
and then also just for fun I have we can
spin up one of these on the non dirty
cow note and I'll show you that it also
doesn't work just to verify that I'm not
like completely fooling you all
so if we delete the old
create the new will grab one of these
again and our satire is going to be sad
again
Oh so now if we switch back to the
slides basically what we learned is that
you can run custom profiles you can stop
bad things from happening if you know
that they're there usually the default
docker profile would block these things
there's actually a page that I wrote in
the docker repo that has like 20-plus
vulnerabilities that were stopped by the
default profile but this was just a fun
example for something that was not and
in other cases I would try like I said
to modify the profile without breaking
everyone which in this case it cannot be
so the cool thing about this is that in
gke if you run with optin for automatic
upgrades for gke no pools this would
never happen because we control the OS
for all the nodes so that's definitely
something you should think about because
we know about these things we upgrade
them no it's for you and then you don't
even have to worry like did I miss a
node do I need to do some sort of custom
profile all that it's pretty great and
other great features of like the OS that
we use are it's a super minimal base
really everything has to be running
containers there's a firewall that drops
all network connections except for SSH
by default it's the default noted image
for all of gke and it's based off Chrome
OS which has really been like tried and
tested as a great security operating
system the entire file system is mounted
as read-only and then certain file
mounts are remounted again as like varla
docker needs to be executable and
writable and your home and bar and a
stateful partition mount can hold
persisted state over time but that's
like literally it so super great that
gke you could possibly never have this
happen now I'm going to pass back to
Alex to cover the road map for the
future Thank You Jess oh yeah
so for the last section I'd like to talk
a little bit about the kubernetes
security roadmap you know full
disclaimer this is an open source
project and Google container engine
inherits whatever kubernetes upstream
does we obviously don't control it so
these are somewhat speculative future
directions we're looking the community
many people of the community share these
goals but there's no guarantee as to
what the future will will bring of
course so two parts to this first I'm
going to talk about some of the more
long-term goals that we have the
problems that we'd like to solve and
then the second half of this I'll talk
about what we might expect to land with
kubernetes one six one seven one eight
over the next six months so we talked a
little bit about security model and
stages Jeff just gave us a nice
introduction to single tenant with
multiple identities and then this notion
of cooperative soft multi-tenancy what
we'd like to see though is hard
multi-tenancy over time so this would be
where those security boundaries between
the multiple tenants of a cluster become
much more strongly enforced and I'll
talk a little bit about that in a moment
we might also want to see things like
better resource isolation if I have two
containers running in different
processes on the same machine maybe i
one of them ends up trashing my l2 cache
and that causes the other one to run
more slowly so there are some
interesting things in terms of looking
at cycles per instruction that you might
want to do in terms of trying to get
better resource isolation between these
different systems if you want to think
about like what would that maybe look
like we'll well know that we've met the
hard multi-tenancy goal if you were a
provider and you said yeah I'm happy to
have you know somebody from company a
give me some code whatever it is and
I'll run it and Company B gives me some
other code and we'll run it and they're
running on the same system the same
cluster the same nodes so if you had
hard multi-tenancy it's really about
this this hard isolation and just
because you don't necessarily want to
run third-party code from multiple
companies this might also be useful to
you inside your organization maybe you
have multiple different departments
maybe you have multiple teams this kind
of thing might also helpful in that case
so just talk to us about a cluster and
the project as a security boundary and
gave you this slide that you saw earlier
we'd like to change this instead of
everything being the same authenticated
identity the pods having the same
permissions what we'd like to see
instead is something where the namespace
and pod become much more of a boundary
than they are today so this would mean
things like the authorization
permissions could be granted at a
namespace resource level so if we look
at the example here you might see team
one has a namespace and they're running
their front ends in read their databases
are in yellow
maybe there's another team team two
they've got their own set up with front
ends and databases shown below in blue
and green and the three nodes here are
hosting the same pods as before but now
we have better notions of separation
between them in this case maybe the
nodes have their individual identities
and per node permissions the pods have
identity with fine-grained permissions
and we could even maybe think about how
the pods could have limited network
access to just whatever is necessary for
them so let's walk through these four
things and talk about the user scenarios
that those would reflect so
authorization permissions at the
namespace resource level so we'd like to
move that to the per namespace per
resource permissions today everything
has routine cluster and that means that
cluster is a boundary instead what we'd
like to do is take advantage of this
security principle least privilege
should be familiar to many people in
security right and so the users and the
system should have the least privilege
possible also the workloads so for
example if one user of the cluster is
Alice she would like to be able to want
to make sure that she can list the HR
serv uh sorry the engineering services
because she's a member of that team but
she shouldn't be able to go and pull
down HR profiles offer letters things
like that maybe Bob can create things in
the test namespace because he's a member
of the testing team but he shouldn't be
able to access things in prod unless
he's a member of your on-call rotation
for example or maybe your scheduler
needs to be able to know what the state
of the nodes are and the state of the
pods are in the system there's really no
need for your scheduler to be able to
read your HTTP certificates so it should
not be able to read the secrets file as
far as the nodes go we'd like to move
them to have per node identity and per
node permissions so right now each of
your nodes can read any of the secrets
in your system they can read any of the
pods in the system
that's okay for today but we'd like to
really move this to the least privileged
model so in this case some example might
be if I have a node it should only be
able to read data about pods that are
scheduled on that node if a pod is
running on some other node in the system
there's really no need for it to be able
to read that similarly it should be able
to read secrets for the things running
on itself but it shouldn't be able to
read secrets for things that it doesn't
need to know about and if we get to this
point then a compromised node will not
allow any additional escalation through
the kubernetes api you'll be able to
access things that happen to live on
that node but if there are 500 other
nodes in your system it won't be able to
do things that reflect on them
third we would like pause to have their
own identity and permissions so as I
mentioned now if you have a default
surface account the default service
account has full admin capability on the
cluster instead we would like to move to
a model where you have to actively grant
workloads permissions so if you want to
create your cron job it would be
reasonable to say yes my cron job should
be able to create pods in the system or
yes whatever my other extension is
that's going to collect statistics about
the things running on the system and
create a dashboard that lets me do some
amount of visualization it should also
be able to have these things but if it's
just your nginx running on your cluster
and genetics really should not be able
to go and delete all of your pods your
deployments and so on similarly if you
have namespaces if you're running a pod
in one particular namespace maybe it can
access things within that localized
namespace but other namespaces that are
isolated from it it should not be able
to have access to and then fourth
network policy so we'd like to move from
all workloads receiving traffic from
anywhere on the network to having
network control policy sorry network
connectivity controllable by policy so
this case would be we have a front-end
system maybe a back-end system the
front-end should be able to talk to the
backends but the front ends maybe
shouldn't be able to talk to each other
and maybe your front-end shouldn't be
able to go out to the public internet
and do other things and we have some
basic support for network policy right
now it requires some external plugins
and so we're going to iterate on that
over time I also want to talk a little
bit about a couple of other features so
just talked about app armour and sect
comp and SELinux we would like to have
support for more security contexts so no
new privileges is a particularly nice
flag and it carries over between fork
and clone and exec Vee and what it does
is it stops new privileges from being
added to a process so that way even if
the initial process can't do something
it can't then create some separate
process give that other process more
permissions and then compromise your
system that way another example of the
kinds of things we hear about is binary
verification so today kubernetes
supports an image policy webhook so that
for example every time a request comes
in to create a pod to run a container
it'll take that image and pass it off to
the image policy service which can come
back with image allowed or image denied
we'd like to expand on that basic
support that's there and add audit
logging for the image policy checks so
that you can have a full trail of what
images were allowed who was trying to
create them and if you have support for
break glass it's a production emergency
please just run it ignore that it's not
signed make sure that that gets locked
as well and so that way you can do
forensics afterwards and do to figure
out what happened on your cluster we've
also had some people talk about binary a
verification of kubernetes and its
add-ons so we're shipping all of these
official containers right now they do
not have any attestation as to whether
they're the right container or system or
not and so one of the things that might
come in over time is allowing the
kubernetes itself to verify those
containers that it's running for it's
controllers the cube proxy the dns the
cube lid and so on and make sure that it
only runs fully verified system
components if that's something you'd
like to have happen so with that I'm
gonna switch gears to our last little
section here kubernetes 1/6 I'll talk
about the next releases after that so we
expect that to be released an open
source towards the end of March Google
container engine should start picking it
up and making it available shortly
thereafter and then over time once we
verified that it says stable as we hope
it to be we would then stew the
automatic upgrades to that version for
any existing clusters so as far as
security model goes we'll have a single
tenant with identities and the
beginnings of soft multi-tenancy and
pods will should not
have root on the cluster by default some
of the highlights is that we're getting
this our back system that's been some of
the main focus over the last three
months getting that enabled by default
and giving people those richer
capabilities to control their system
we've also been adding a lot of
identities to the infrastructure
components the nodes the controllers and
so on and many of them have more limited
permissions than they do with 1 5 and
below but not all of them so kubernetes
is on a three month release cycles so
scumming in June 2017 near the end of
that month we expect kubernetes 1-7 to
ship as far as the security model for
that goes it should be a pretty decent
soft multi-tenancy and in particular if
you are able to escape a container on
that escalation should be limited to
just the one node that it's running on
so some of the highlights from a
security perspective that we might
expect to see are finishing the the
limiting enforcement of system
components such that each particular
node can only do what it wants to do
what it needs to do we expect our audit
logging to get much more comprehensive
to include many more sources of what's
going on in the cluster and possibly
also have capabilities to ship those
right now it's written to a file on the
master itself ship those off to network
endpoints and then we also hear a lot
about certificate rotation being able to
take those certificates in your system
and rotate them over time there's more
speculative it's things like improved
secrets management right now the secrets
are written to at CD as a database and
they're stored in plain text on
container engine the disk itself is
encrypted at rest so we do have some
amount of encryption at rest for gke but
in kubernetes itself they're in plain
text in at CDs so you really need to
make sure that people can't just read
your at CD database there's also talk
about runtime isolation improvements so
you saw how good set comp could be we'd
like to see that maybe become the
default in kubernetes and require people
to say no no I have something that is
going to require extra-special syscalls
and I'm going to trust it to do that
give you this pod permissions to do
those extra things once we've done all
that three months later again September
2017 that's when we expect kubernetes
1-8 to land and at that point our
security model
starting what will probably be a long
road to hard multi-tenancy unclear at
this point where we're not looking
forward quite that far yet we're still
in the ones six of shipping phase and
starting to plan for one seven some of
the things that we might see are VM
based runtimes via the container runtime
interface that would provide an extra
layer of Defense and depth more binary
verification potentially that better
resource isolation between containers
that I mentioned and then also large
organizations might like to be able to
specify policy everyone in my org should
run with read-only file systems you
can't create a pod in my service that
has that flag disabled unless of course
you're in the special whitelist and so
to give you a brief recap we talked
about four things security boundaries we
talked about Identity and Access
Management the runtime security and and
justice demo and then a little bit of
the roadmap for kubernetes security and
so with that I'd like to invite people
to come up to the two mics for questions
if anyone wants to chat privately
afterwards as privately as you can here
we'll go outside if we run over time and
you can meet us in the hallway
[Applause]
[Music]
you